when people talk about big data
they nearly always talk about data
science and data scientists
as well now just as the definition of
big data is still debated
the same is true for the definition of
data science
to some people the terms just a fancier
way of saying statistics and
statisticians
on the other hand other people argue
that data science
is a distinct field it has different
training
techniques tools and goals than
statistics typically has
now that's what we're going to talk
about in this presentation
the first thing that we want to do is we
want to look at what's called the data
science venn diagram
this is a chart that was created by drew
conway in 2010
and what he's arguing here is that data
science involves a combination of three
different skills
the first is statistics that's on the
top right
the second on the bottom is domain
knowledge that you actually know for
instance
about management or advertising and the
one on the top left is coding or being
able to program computers
he's arguing that to get data science a
person needs to be able to do all three
of these
so we're going to talk about each of
these facets one at a time
and in combination with each other
the first component of data science is
statistics which shouldn't be surprising
because we're talking about data science
the trick here is that a lot of things
that go into statistics and mathematics
can be really counter-intuitive
and if you don't have the specific
formal training you can make some really
big mistakes
the second element of data science is
domain knowledge and the idea here is
that a researcher should know about the
topic area that they're working in
so if you're working in say for instance
marketing you need to understand how
marketing works
and that makes it so you can have more
insight and better direct your analyses
and your procedures to match the
questions that you might have
for instance there's a wonderful blog
post by svetlana secular of gartner inc
where she writes organizations already
have people who know their own data
better than mystical data scientists
this is a key the internal people
already gained experience and ability to
model
research and analyze learning hadoop
a common software or framework for
dealing with big data is
easier than learning a company's
business and that really underscores the
importance of domain knowledge in data
science
the third element of drew conway's data
science diagram is coding
and this refers to computer programming
ability
now it doesn't need to be complicated
you don't have to have a phd in computer
science
a little bit of python programming can
go a very long way
it's because this allows for the
creative exploration and manipulation of
data sets
and especially when you consider the
variety of data that's part of big data
the ability to combine data that comes
in different formats can be a really
important thing
and that often requires some coding
ability
it also helps to develop algorithmic
thinking or thinking in linear steps by
steps to get through a problem
next we'll talk about combinations of
two of these elements at a time
the first one is statistics and domain
knowledge without coding
this is what conway calls traditional
research and this is where a researcher
works within their field of expertise
uses common tools for working with
familiar data formats
it's extremely productive and nearly all
existing research has been conducted
this way
the second combination is statistics in
coding without substantive expertise
this is what conway refers to as machine
learning
this is not to be confused with data
mining
machine learning is where an algorithm
or a program updates itself
and evolves to perform a specific
analytical task
the most familiar example of this is
spam filters in email
in which the user or a whole large group
of users identify messages as spam or
not spam
and the formula that the program uses to
determine whether something is spam
updates with each new piece of
information to have increased accuracy
the more you use it
the third combination here is domain
knowledge and coding without statistics
now conway labels this a danger zone
with the idea being that you have enough
knowledge to be dangerous
while there are problems with this i'll
mention two things
first conway himself mentions that it
seems very unlikely that a person could
develop both programming expertise and
substantive knowledge without also
learning some math and statistics
so he says it would be a sparsely
populated category
and i believe that's true on the other
hand
there's some really important data
science contributions that come out of
this combination
including for instance what are called
word counts which we'll talk about later
it's simple stuff these are procedures
that do not require sophisticated
statistics
you're just counting how often things
occur and you can get important insights
out of that
so i wouldn't write this one off
completely i would say though that like
conway
it's not likely that a person could
develop expertise in both coding
and their domain without getting the
math and statistics as well
and finally of course there's all three
of these things statistics
domain knowledge and coding at once and
that is the most common definition of
data science